one of the ways that the study of
literature the study of film differs
from the study of technical things and
the reason I teach it is that it belongs
to everyone that it's valuable for
everyone not everyone needs to know
about quantum mechanics but I believe
everyone should and if they don't I feel
they're impoverished know how to read a
good story and joy plays know how to
enjoy the movies so I feel that what I'm
giving my students is in some sense
something even more valuable to them
because it will be something that
they'll have with them for their whole
lives for their whole career one of the
things MIT students sometimes often do
not realize is that a very large number
of them do not end up making their
living in the areas in which they
majored but all of them end up wanting
to go to the movies all of them end up
with a capacity to read and enjoy
literature and I hope that coming out of
my classes they'll do those things with
greater joy and with greater
intelligence one of the things I hope
all of you will have when you come out
of this course is a much more confident
sense of how to look at movies not to
spoil your enjoyment of kicking back in
looking at a stupid Schwarzenegger
entertainment if you want to not to make
you feel guilty about that but to make
you be able to tell the difference
between something like that and what
I'll call a work of art implicit in my
film course is an admiration for a
certain kind of achievement an
admiration for a certain kind of artist
an artist like Jean Renoir the great
filmmaker if I were deprived of the
pleasure of seeing boudu again for the
rest of my days I would never forget
that grass that dust and their
relationship to the liberty of a [ __ ]
the point of this exercise is to remind
you of the immense power the potency of
even a single camera move think what
that 180 degree pan suggests as bezu
brilliantly argues for us so the
conclusion then is that the visual style
of a film of our certain films anyway
can express a moral vision and by moral
vision I don't mean moralistic what's
more what's what's didactically right
and wrong but a vision of having to do
with the values and assumptions you make
about the nature of the world there's a
moral
implicit in the tentative necessity' n--
see the retarding impulse of to dwell
and linger on things in in the in
Renoir's camera and in the basic habits
of of poetic realism that you will see
brilliantly embodied in the film you're
going to watch tonight grand illusion
because i want to set up as a candidate
for their admiration an alternative to
wall street an alternative to
entrepreneurial genius I admire John
Renoir is genius or Orson Welles is
genius or James Joyce's genius universe
is more than they invite and then I then
I admire what entrepreneurs I respect
what entrepreneurs do but I am in awe of
what great artists do and and and of
what great I have got great doctors to
what while we're on the subject it was
I'm uneasy about the extent to which
even in within MIT s culture we've
become so preoccupied by what we might
call commercial or financial success
instead of the kind of lasting success
that great art or the practice of
medicine or the practice of Nursing or
dare I say it the practice of teaching
might also embody